shelli's selling off around half of its
North Sea oil production that's the oil
giant continues its drive to divest
around 30 billion dollars worth of
assets following its takeover last year
of BG Group Chris you're a private
exploration and production company will
pay up to 3 billion pounds for shells
interests in nine all fields as well as
its 10% stake in another field together
those fields account for one hundred and
fifteen thousand barrels of crude oil
per day that's more than half of Shell's
total North Sea production of 211
thousand barrels a day looms surrounding
North Sea oil production has lifted
considerably since Brent crude sunk to
just $27 a barrel last February thanks
to major producers agreeing to cut
production is now more than double that
price but still just around half of what
it cost in the summer of 2014 when I
spoke to Chris halls chief executive
Phil Kirk and asked him why he was
buying the assets from shell we're
buying these assets from shell because
it's immediately gonna catapult us to be
the leading independent in the UK
focused on UK production day one we're
going to be about a hundred and fifteen
thousand barrels a day with 350 million
barrels of 2p reserves and a staff of as
the transition goes through around 400
highly competent people that we can use
as a basis for growth I Michelle are a
great company though what do you know
that shell doesn't I think as you know
that shell bought BG Group plc last year
in a in a world-class acquisition and
promise the market they divest 30
billion of assets really that gives us
the opportunity to acquire assets that
probably wouldn't have been on the
market otherwise we pay a fair price and
both parties are happy at anything it's
that we know things different to shell
or any better perhaps have a different
way of tackling their to-do list I mean
the operating costs on these fields are
just $15 a barrel there aren't many more
efficiency gains that can be wrought out
of the mother $50 a barrel is it's very
competitive allows us to to generate a
significant amount of cash looking to
the future something I've always been
passionate about the easiest way to
improve unit costs is to bring more
hydrocarbons across the platforms
so while there are parts of these
reserves that you will hope to exploit
that she'll perhaps wouldn't have I
think in different ways around the
portfolio there are there are reserves
that we will we will drill and we'll
seek to develop that maybe were in
material for shale or viewed in a global
context wouldn't pass their hurdles
whereas for us who were focused on the
UK with access to significant capital we
can make those decisions now you're
taking on some 400 staff as part of this
acquisition how secure are all of those
jobs I've been with the staff this
afternoon in the Town Hall down at the
shell the shell building I've said to
them that as part the transition we're
not looking to make any layoffs we're
preserving terms and conditions and
actually the whole the whole story is
about growth
it's not about cost-cutting is about
efficiency and more hydrocarbons and
that was well received so this is
obviously quite a big acquisition it'll
probably take you time to get your arms
around it but are you looking to do
further acquisitions in the North Sea at
some point in the future yeah we re and
I'm primary focus is obviously a safe
transition we've got all the regulator's
partner approvals to go through but we
have more more firepower more capital my
backers and myself are interested in
further acquisitions and we think there
will be the opportunity and what are
your expectations on the price of Brent
for the rest of the year as part of this
deal we've actually hedged out our end
price it's around about $55 so it's it's
more academic to us I think long term
we're slightly higher than that we're
not aggressive in our target this is
obviously a big vote of confidence in
the UK continental shelf why is it do
you think that some of the majors have
been turning their back on the region a
lot of the majors run global portfolios
they're looking for materiality it's
more difficult for them to run their
business with with incremental
opportunities I think that's one of the
one of the main reasons a lot of maybe
refocused and retrenched on on the u.s.
launch
or unsure opportunities and to be nice
that opens the field for people like is
something that my backers have spotted
with myself and I think we're on the
cusp of a very Renaissance